bonjour et bienvenue sur 10 godall tv
pour ce championnat du monde d'échecs
2016 entre donc maquilleuse carsen le
tenant du titre champion du monde
norvégien face à sergei k yakine le
russe donc qu'on est à la deuxième
partie la première partie on a vu cette
première une partie nulle dans cette
ouverture trop pauvres ce qui donc ici
karatina les blancs que va-t-il jouer
qu'à va être un peu le thème du match
avec les blancs pour gagner qui on va le
voir tout de suite avec donc cette
partie qui s'engagent au premier coup
avec le coup et bien eu quatre voilà
donc car les kin varie par rapport à
ascq à jouer car scène en tout cas c'est
pas la même ouverture le vaut bien
c'est l'ouverture ouvertes du que roy et
qu'arsène répond par le symétrique e5
dans quoi on va tomber beaucoup de
possibilités encore défense russe
défense philidor contre gambie etc etc
pourquoi pas italienne etc et on va voir
carrière 3d là donc on se dirige vers
des partis italienne écossaise ou
espagnol cava lycée si c'est maintenant
qu'on va savoir de quoi il s'agit en
fonction du coût des blancs il ya
plusieurs possibilités bien sûr ça
dépend le plus souvent soit on pousse
des cats tout de suite son sort ce four
soit ces quatre soit en b5 et bien que
choisit kayak insi préparation bien sûr
faux baiser est alors tombé 5
il ya encore des possibilités il ya donc
encore des sous variante évidemment
c'est quand même caractéristique ce coût
de la partie espagnole où la fameuse
bien sûr henry lopez rue lopez qui donc
dans son livre 2561 pour la première
fois dans l'histoire du jeu avait mis au
point cette ouverture pour contrer et
bien là la prétention de damiano disque
damiano lui proposé que carrie et ses 6
soit la meilleure réponse des noirs et
rue lopes avait répondu que doublé 5e
était sans doute le coup le plus
avantageux dans ce cas là pour pour les
blancs cette fameuse partis espagnols
ont fait pression sur ce cavalier avec
l'idée de prendre le cavalier tôt ou
tard et de manger le pion
deux cents mais en fait en réalité c'est
difficile de les manger tout de suite
parce que même en cas de prise prises et
cavaliers prend le 5 est bien la dame
ici des huit peut venir des quatre
attaquants le carrier le pion mais en
tout cas la pression est là et tôt ou
tard la menace pourrait devenir
d'actualité donc les noirs voient la
joue à 6 puisqu'ils n'ont pas peur de
les champs vont ces six les blancs
daughdrill la paire de fou puisque on
entend un four n'a plus qu'un pas qu'on
a pu la paire alors que les noirs
pauvres et la paire on prendrait du pion
des bizarrement dans ce cas là avec les
noirs c'est la fameuse variantes des
changes dont laurent frayssinet
d'ailleurs en français le grand maître
laurent frayssinet double champion de
france et était est un grand spécialiste
et qu'il est aux joueurs qu'il a joué
avec succès fischer aussi jouer ça et
pas peur de rentrer ses ventes des
changes qui est comme tactique très
technique dans une finale assez assez
rapide
hélas ici eh bien on joue aussi bien sûr
la grande variante kayak in propose de
rentrer dans la fameuse grandes
variantes de l'espagnol g 20 de la rue
lopez fou à quatre on décide donc de ne
pas prendre aux gars de la pression on
invite les noirs à ça fait bien peu il
dame filmé en jouant b5 sa chasse le fou
certainement le fou peut venir en b3
attaqué m 7
mais on s'affaiblit un peu les pionniers
la dame a cédé grands thèmes vous pouvez
revoir toutes les parties des modèles tv
sur cette ouverture espagnol on voit
toutes ses variantes dans différentes
parties il y en a beaucoup
c'est devant très connu vous me fischer
jouer de 10 et de cette ouverture qu'on
pouvait la jouer comme ça pendant 20 ou
25 où il disait on trait la vache
voilà c'est un peu geste mécanique pour
retraire un petit peu le maximum
d'imposition c'est assez facile à
trouver l'écouté oric en fait donc on
continue
kyle 6 le coût standard mais non les
noirs donc ne joue pas tout de suite b5
il prépare le petit rock assez
rapidement d'abord ils s'attaquent eux
quatre ils vont ensuite sortir le fouet
une fois une fois qu'ils sont proches de
faire rock il peut jouer b5 et à ce
moment là
ils finissent leur développement assez
facilement petit rock pour les blancs
fawcett voilà on sur le fou on peut
aussi envisager de mettre en 600cc bien
alors attention parce que maintenant
en cas de prise prise du cavalier pour
les blancs les noirs pour rejouer quand
même dame des quatre ici attaquant les
deux mais après il ya un tour eu un qui
commence à créer des visas vis ici trois
heures- néant par ok mais bon en fait on
voit bien que c'est quand même assez
facile pour les noirs des rockets donc
des 3 voilà alors se foutent important
des trois je protège le 4 et ça veut
dire aussi que j'abandonne un des quatre
rapide ça ne vise pas le coût des quatre
rapides et d'autres variantes plus lente
de fin différente de l'espagnol on joue
plutôt la tour en main pour protéger le
pion et ensuite on a joué ses trois pour
que le fonds puisse revenir en c2 et c3
aide à la poussée des quatre on veut
rentrer dans le centre alors un jeune
des trois on pourra jouer des quatre
aussi plus tard mais voilà c'est quand
même tout petit peu différent donc becel
maintenant attention puisque maintenant
qu'on protège des sur le pion aux quatre
la menace fou prend puis on prend car il
prend est une vraie de vraie grosse
menace on perd un pion central sans rien
puisque tout est protégé au centre il
n'y a pas de contre attaque
donc là il faut à faire quelque chose
donc b5 c'est bien sur le coup four b3
et l'on pourrait se dire non je continue
à chasser le foot ça marche pas parce
qu'on jouait en carrière celle du fou
n'a pas de gaz mais on perd à toujours
pareil le pion aux 5
il faut d'abord défendre ce pion ce que
fait qu arsène tout de suite des six
protège et maintenant attention aux
menaces entre guillemets pseudomonas
comme c'est pas une bonne note
définitive bien sûr mais c'est quand
même une menace c'est john callas scène
pour éliminer ce trou se foutrait
important pour lui blanc voilà ici on a
la petite chaîne de pions
blanche ici et le fouet au delà des
pions dont qui contrôle une superbe
diagonale ici surtout que le roi
waroquet donc en plus s'ils visent le
roi des rien donc c'est fou très
puissant voilà il ne faut pas le que le
blanc le ced contre un cavalier à la
limite contre le fou de cas de casse
blanche adverse qui pourrait venir en
russie ce procès changer pourquoi pas
mais pas par contre pas contraints de
travailler en laissant le fou de cases
blanches des noirs ici avoir de très
belles cases de trait un très beau jeu
sur l'échiquier
c'est hors de question de lâcher seront
donc voilà on joue à trois carabines
voix 3 il aurait pu jouer ses trois
oscille sans doute un c3 et en 4k ya
cinq ans j'ai foncé 2 mais je pensais
pas l'idée on va voir incendie à kariat
keynes morse un début un peu connue
quand même mais mais c'est intéressant
de noter ces petites subtilités on l'a
donc à trois c'est donc l'idée ici
simplement sur kaia sen fou fois deux
petits rock la qualité 3 voilà donc
kyling joue le cavalier en c3 anouk s'il
avait joué ses trois courants mais vous
ne vous cachera pas punir en c3 dont il
fallait qu'il aille en d2 et souvent du
tour ou un lecavalier en référé star ac'
stericsson la scala l'aurait perdu du
temps avec le coude et 3 donc je pense
donc c'est pas c'est pas la même
variante en fait deux en termes
stratégiques je dirais mais sur ces
primaires en tout court mais surtout en
termes stratégiques c'est pas les mêmes
idées en c3 mais on contrôle des singes
notamment là donc on on veut viser quand
même la case centrale en dessin pourquoi
pas venir des scènes je sais pas s'il
veut changer ce qui relève six ou pas
mais voilà c'est quand même
développement différent et il garde le
fou sur ces diagonales
c'est surtout ça l'idée avec le coût à 3
le cahier à 5,2 très bien pourquoi les
noirs jouent les coups comme cavaillès m
malgré le flou peut venir en a deux eh
bien ça veut dire que les noirs aussi
veulent peut-être plus tard joué le coup
c'est 5 ça rime 5 août standard en
espagnol
si on joue ces cinq avec les noirs ont
des contrôles très très bien caisse des
caractères très difficile d'envisager
des quatre avec les mets et blanc donc
c'est c'est un coût tout à fait tout à
fait intéressant il aurait pu on peut
jouer sans doute ces scènes tout de
suite mais carsen préfère quand même
éliminé tout de suite s'offre donc il
joue regardez voilà faut aussi donc il
n'a pas peur que les blancs trail en
doublant et pionne c'est pas très grave
nous mais plus ici parce que du coup
cette cette masse de pions noirs
contrôle très bien le centre et blanc
sont sont repoussés ils peuvent pas
aller faire grand chose sur le centre et
en plus on a libéré la colonne f qui
pourrait qui pourrait devenir du coup un
thème d'attac
voilà on a une seule colonne là il est
ouverte qui tape sur le cavalier pour
hervé léger pour on va doubler autour de
cette colonne je ne sais pas mais
pourquoi pas un seul petit attaque avec
les bios mais mine de rien c'est les
blancs qui sont sous pression ici ils
n'ont pas l'équivalent ils n'ont pas de
quoi ouvrir rapidement
de la même façon tout en question pas
peur est là donc d4
voilà donc les blues jouent maintenant
des quatre on n'a pas joué ses trois
donc on est prêt en cas de prise
reprendre swag la dame soit probablement
plus du cavalier attaquants 6 forçant
les noir sans doute à prendre un à deux
on peut aussi là tout de suite on menace
quand même puis on prend 1,5 et bien sûr
celle a menacé de prendre un pion et si
les noms reviennent avec le cavalier
bien sûr attention des 5 et une
fourchette donc on peut pas faire
n'importe quoi avec les noirs on est
quasiment obligé de procéder à des
échanges
il faut d'abord on élimine d'abord le
fou tout reprend fou prend tout reprend
pourquoi tout reprend son travail est
bien placé et finalement parce que s'il
prend un cadeau il faudra qu'ils
auraient tous la tour brodeuse elle peut
revenir un aussi revenir bon ou alors on
peut envisager aussi on pousse les pions
on arrive à pousser les pions sais pas
comment mais imaginons que ce soit
possible et notre cas là à tours pour
eux qu ici sur la deuxième bon un peu
lent mais bon pourquoi pas prendre la
tour c'est pas très grave
la position est pas
ouverte on n'est pas pressé de remplacer
ces pièces on préfère garder notre
qu'avaliser ici ou contrôler les cas
centrale on a deux claviers magnifique
qui sont dans leur case quasiment
optimale donc enfin deux pas de raison
de les bouger en notant que si on
travaille on peut évidemment et puis en
quatre ans pris tout de suite quand même
un gros problème aussi voilà tour et 8
ici tour à 1 voilà il revient avec la
tour tranquille aux voiliers pas pas de
problème pour kyle king c'est un peu la
rampe par contre on voit bien que là il
perd un peu de temps donc on peut se
dire qu'étant donné ses pairs de temps
tandis que les blancs pas vraiment
menacé des choses au niveau de centrales
ont poussé tard le coup de quatre bons
ils ont bien senti et leurs pièces mais
parlant dire qu'ils aient davantage
il n'y avait pas la paire de poumons
rien du tout pas caler ses quatre pour
les noirs maintenant attention c'est un
cavalier ici qui était à l'abandon dit
hein c'est à dire à l'extérieur de
l'échiquier on le ramène vers le centre
parce que il faut qu'ils contrôlent eu
des casses dans le camp adverse il faut
pas avoir une pièce comme ça qui est un
peu hors jeu il va pouvoir être chassé
par le coupé 3 mais il peut revenir en b
6 et pourquoi pas ensuite il pourrait
venir en 17
et pourquoi pas ces cinq un jour ou
l'autre si on est changeant décati 6e
puis on disparaît où il peut aussi venir
en dix-sept pourquoi pas en réfute ni
angers 6 visée lacazette 4 mois ce
cavalier quand même très libre il paraît
pas il n'y a pas de problème et donc ils
bougent pour trouver sa meilleure case
il est en train de chercher sa mère
quand donc les blancs voilà très bien
sûr protège de 4 enfin très important et
tout le temps on est quand même obligé
de vous tourner sur protège ce pion ce
qui nous permet en cas de prise d'avoir
l'esprit tranquille on protège du
clavier on protège de la tour donc même
si les noirs peuvent attaquer du
cannabis et de la tour il aura jamais de
problème
la tour quand même mieux placés en
vainquant fin on n'a pas à l'idée de
jouer car de toute façon donc on garde
ses pions normalement tranquille où et
on vise une bonne une bonne tension au
centre une bonne pression centre une
pression sur celle qu on peut menacer
des comptes des trois on peut regarder
d'ailleurs tiens si les blancs avaient
joué ici b3 qui est une idée avec l'idée
lecavalier bouge
on prend ensuite en cinq prises prisée
car elle est pro on gagne on a l'air de
gagner une pièce mais simplement ça
marche pas on n'est même pas oublier aux
pourrait prendre des cadres d'abord non
ça marche pas parce qu'on fait qu a et b
ça marche pas d'avoir qu'en fait tout
cas c'est pas très gênant parce qu'après
pions prends 200
simplement les noirs retrait de 1,5 et à
imaginons que les blancs belle coupe
d'abord et choc les dames par exemple
pour prendre prend et maintenant on
prend de plus en cinq bons mais c'est
facile au regard n'est pas loin on joue
par exemple coussin peu fous ces scènes
où guillaume fouet fuite et la tour
attaque le clavier et derrière il ya
pire 4 est en prise avec la torreton
pluie et alors si on joue comme f4 peau
c'est de s'accrocher aux pions toujours
essayer parce qu'elle a et noir pourrait
venir faire un échec avec le font ses
cinq premières choses sur le foot avec
gain de temps sur roy runner et
maintenant garde est magnifique
hop décalé la partie est terminée on ne
peut arrêter parce que la lienne clouage
terrible on va prendre sans doute
ensuite en 5 voire même en 4 c'est à
dire que là par exemple si les blanches
fou des deux on pourrait faire caler
prend 1,4 en cas de prison prend du four
b2 la tour bouge on peut soit prendre à
300 reprend dans le cinq avec ses
racines catastrophe toutou qui tombe
puisque dès que les pions ne sont plus
liés au centre c'est une catastrophe
voyez donc ça marche pas du tout il n'y
a rien à faire donc il faut bien
préparer tout ça donc tout re un eelam
et alentours s'est vite voilà alors tour
c'est 8
on comprend les que ce coût est logique
si on a compris ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure c'est à dire qu'on peut jouer
dans un espagnol souvent ces 5
voilà donc ans et 8 on n'est jamais mal
placée avec la tour donc voilà bon après
c'est toujours un peu curieux de mètres
la tour d'abord derrière le pion le
pousser mais bon ça dépend des
estimations en tout cas c'est un coup
c'est un coup tranquille qui préparent
des coups logique donc ça peut pas être
mauvais coup c'est un bon coup h3 très
souvent joué dans l'espagnol h3 petite
fenêtre pour le roi en cas de
du couloir très tard dans la partie et
puis surtout votre la case g4 donc on
empêche des cas légers cas de menace sur
quatre niveaux et l'autre idée aussi
c'est que souvent la quasi quatre aides
le carré f3 d'ailleurs le cavalier peut
venir en h2 puis il y avait quatre aides
en cas de prise donc on reprend du
pillon l'intérêt d'un homme puisse
prendre mais on reprend du pur ans ça
ramène un pion vers le centre et ça te
fait une masse de pions dangereuse face
au vent noir ça ouvre la colonne h en
plus peut être un thème voilà bon on
n'est pas là h6 lenoir tranquillou
pareil pas de problème
b 3 voilà ça y est alors donc la
vingtaine on joue le coup b3 qui va
chasser ce cavalier qui quand même peu
menaçants et puis surtout sans doute on
veut mettre le fou sur b2
parce que où va ce fou ce un problème de
développement des pièces faut trouver
des bonnes cases suffit pas de sortir
les pièces faut trouver des bonnes cases
pour les pièces donc si j'avais joué fou
g5 ce n'est pas probable puisque je
proposais d'éventuels échanges bon je
peux venir ensuite en h4 g3 petit g2 si
je me fais attaquer bon c'est discutable
c'est pas forcément terrible mais c'est
jouable
et ici on joue en b3 nos solange de
chasse le cavaly mais c'est pas
tellement l'idée c'est que je libère
acas b2 voilà je veux venir en b2 parce
qu'en b2g une magnifique diagonale ici
pour le fou parce que de toute façon
ceux qui ont 5 soit il va prendre des
quatre soit on pourra prendre nous mêmes
en selle avec un fou qui ajoute de la
pression avec lecavalier
donc on a un fou très très bien placé si
en b2c sans doute sa meilleure case en
plus ils inattaquable et en plus il a un
petit oeil aussi sur le pion à 3 ans
rester en b 2 ce qui fait que cette tour
pourra bouger sans craindre
tôt ou tard la tacc du fou de cases
noires ici il faut adverse ou tout noir
sur sur le pur à 3 voilà donc en d2
c'est vraiment une superbe casse pour ce
fou donc trouver la meilleure case c'est
important qu'elle avait six personnes
jouent le seul coup quasiment on va
parvenir à 5 s'il est venu en c4 c'est
pas pour revenir à 5
c'était pour aller en v6 on l'avait vu
en b 6 mai elle contrôle un peu le
centre peut aider à soutenir un petit
peu pourquoi pas une poussée des 5
ça pourrait s'envisager tout le tard tu
as tout de suite le ton tard
ou alors il peut aussi revenir en 17 et
fuite g6 par exemple on me dit qu'on l'a
dit et f4 surtout quand le fou il est
tombé de là on a une belle 84
voilà plein possibilité ou dessins coup
c'est fou cavalli qui est tranquille
plan b si lille est pas si mal et un peu
dominé mais bon on peut pas dire qu'ils
leurs enjeux noble la foulée 2 et là
regardez tranquillou pour les noirs
fouet fuite
voilà de toute façon avec 8 le fou
gardent l'oeil aux sites possibles sur
a3 même si maison s'est bien défendu et
surtout en jouant fuite
on libère l'action de la tour voilà
c'est à dire que la tour 8 maintenant
protège scène est aussi menace tôt ou
tard de prendre en d4 et donc la tour et
le cavalier font une double pression sur
4 mais s'est défendu deux fois on a vu
donc à point pour les blancs mais voilà
c'est mais petite pression
supplémentaire en mettant un fou sur sa
meilleure case où il n'est pas attaqué
ou gêne pas la tour donc les blancs
maintenant choisissent de prendre puis
on prend 1,5 et la bouffe petit coup à 4
intéressant à quatre petites pressions
sur les dames voilà c'est ce qu'on en
dise tout début
si vous rappeler c'est que les blancs un
peu un site les noirs attaqué le foot
bessin le fou qui était venu en bessin à
604 bessin bon très bien on gagne de
l'espace mais on s'expose aussi à se
faire attaquer les pions pour ses
classiques aux échecs ça allait beaucoup
d'ouverture comme ça où 1 et caen pousse
l'adversaire à noisy pousse ses pions
m'a dit on voit les pieds au centre
c'est sûr tu prends de l'espace c'est
qu'ils aient davantage mais le revers de
la médaille c'est que ces plans sont
proches de moi donc je prends les
attaques et plus facilement aussi
voilà c'est plus difficile à attaquer
les pions dans le camp adverse que s'ils
sont bien avancées déjà après presque
dans notre camp où on peut commencer à
les contre-attaqués donc les noirs
jouent ces 6 ils mettent leurs pions sur
casse blanche couleur opposée de celle
du fou ce qui est bien vu et ses deux
pions continue à contrôler les cases c4
et surtout la casse des singes
voilà contrôle des cinq très important
avec le pion ça évite tout ultérieure
cavalli des scènes qui pourraient
survenir
c'est terminé il passa et on contrôle
donc à la fois les cases blanches avec
les pions et puis les cases noires avec
le four laissez très complet et en plus
sur la si on prend le prix une scène qui
contrôle ici le contrôle quand même très
très bien tout ça dit très difficile
pour les blancs d'envisager de faire les
choses sur ces cases ya donc ici dans
prend des huit échange de dames on
entend dans une finale pour prendre des
beats et maintenant depuis un premier
essai dans leur attention
on reprend le plus souvent des pions de
l'extérieur vers le centre et en plus la
tour à 1 attention libéré à l'idée de
4,6 à b sur cet accueil que les pions et
pisté l'idée d'ouvrir cette colonie
voilà après apprend mais c'est voilà
cette tour est super active on peut
venir à six attaquants lecavalier
derrière il ya le pion sait si c'est un
tout petit souci et puis aussi on peut
aller sur la fameuse 7e en géant à 7
avec la turquie pourrait doubler a tower
qui pour venir aider au combat il faut
faire attention aussi quand cette tour
bouge simple b 4 cavaliers bouger le
pion le quatrième est en prison donc
attention on s'efface possibilité donc
là où surprenant de khanaqine un peu
inattendu mais intéressant pour ce
camaïeu 2 pas mal cailleux 2 alors lié
qu'à eux deux c'est que gilles hybert
l'action du four b2 mais je donne le
pion aux 4 contre le cuir en scène donc
en cas de pic à l'épreuve quatre
cavaliers prendre 5 protégé par le fou
escale et sans doute à taxer 6 c'est
sans doute l'idée de kajaki non
proposant cet échange car c'est ne
tombons pas là-dedans et a pas envie de
ça il veut garder les deux pions sans
trop y voit pas les échanges et ne pas
avoir des problèmes avec ses pions à 6
et b5 il le sait qu'ils sont un tout
petit peu faible et que les blancs
peuvent les attaquer alors qu'eux-mêmes
voyez comme ils peuvent pas attaquer les
pions ces deux des trois voiliers on
peut pas venir en d2 à cause du khalife
3 n'a rien à faire c'est s'est très bien
défendu parce que c'est dans le camp
blanc c'est très le fils allaient
attaquer dans le camp adverse
donc la foulée sous b4 très intéressant
très bon coup de 400 ou beckham ne
perturbe la tour si la tour sans ma foi
déjà j'ai plus du tout sur le pian 4 qui
deviennent très faible du fait que je
prends protège le pyro scène par exemple
par cavaillé 17
j'ai un gros problème sur quatre qu'il
faut que joe raedle donc c'est pas clair
en plus si je bouge la tour en cas de
prise prise il ya quand même un caillou
2 qui derrière et peut être en l'air
aussi de la tour adverse
donc c'est embêtant ce coup quoi faire
si on joue ces trois bien sûr sa chasse
le fou mais je vous rappelle que ça déjà
ça avance un pion qui du coup ses pions
ne sont plus aussi tranquille puisque la
tour adverse en venant des trois forêts
une petite pression sur ceux qui ont ces
trois même si les protéger et surtout un
jeu dans ces trois blocs m'en fous ce
fou n'a pas pu donc attention c'est
facile de chasser les pièces mais si ça
bloque vos pièces vos propre et ce n'est
pas une bonne idée
donc c'est un coup ça pour perturber
l'organisation des pièces adverses un
coup de perturbations organisationnel on
va dire voilà pour être précis voilà
c'est on essaie de pousser l'adversaire
à faire des fautes de position des
fautes de placement de ces pièces
tombent pas dans le piège mission
khanaqinne issoufou c3 pas de problème
j'ai change quand vous contre le mien
bon même s'il faut b d'eux était un tout
petit peu plus actif que le fouet fuite
mais on voit qu'une fois que le pion des
six est sorti quand même se [ __ ] et
puissant une belle diagonale ici avec la
case bkk c5 qui sont quand même des
cases importante donc bon échange est
fou c'est pas une mauvaise affaire vous
prendre lé prend le car il revient sur
sa case optimale pas trop ce que kara
qui n'a gagné avec kyle de il n'a
peut-être pas d'autres choses à faire
bon on voit que quand même il a il n'y a
pas grand chose proposition est
symétrique
regardez les pions sont se répandre les
épisodes de pion à gauche face à
exactement à deux pions à droite a deux
pions en face et à droite côté droit
pareil capture trouve qu'un pion il n'y
a pas de signes a pas de pas de
dissymétrie tout et tout est
parfaitement en place
c'est très difficile de gagner ce type
de partie en finale donc validé cette on
avait dit que ce qu'avaient ils
pouvaient venir en 17 pour se recycler
et là on décèle maintenant il ne peut
être une nouvelle idée maintenant dans
cette position c'est de niro csn cell et
on continue à faire pression sur soutien
aux quatre sa menace pas le prendre il
défendu quoi qu'on pourrait jouer b4
derrière et si le prendre quand même si
mel en plus ça de toute façon ça ça
bloque les pièces à la défense si vous
bloquez les pièces adversaire la défense
c'est plus difficile pour lui
d'envisager de faire des actions
offensivement donc la torah 6 très bon
coup bien sûr tour à 6 je sors la tour
j'attaque le pion faible en c6 c'est un
coup sur lequel les noirs doivent
répondre tranquillement tour ses huit
voilà c'est très important bien sûr on
ne touche pas ce pion puisque si on
bouge ce pion et bien la casse des 5 fm
et tout de suite les noirs des problèmes
parce que si on arrive à jouer qu'il y
ait des singles ça ça change tout il
faut garder ce pion ces six là où il est
les blancs ont du mal à l'attaqué il ya
que la tour pour l'instant qu'il attaque
et ils contrôlent la casse des 5 es là
un petit coup bk bien joué je pense ça
ici de caraquez il bien sûr enfin c'est
carey qui n'y joue bien c'est sûr mais
la b4 je bloque le pierrot bay 5
pourquoi parce que les noirs aussi
peuples menacés à tout le monde et 4p
quatre cas les bouges et du coup la tour
doit rester à la défense du pion aux
quatre qu'attaquer par le cabinet si par
contre je vous doublez les tours ici
voilà faut pas se permettre des quatre
parce que la touriste y vient pour
doubler si ce site ce qui très bien
faire pression sur cette colonne je vais
pouvoir manoeuvrer
par exemple en jouant tour à sept tours
bessette et la deuxième tour vient et
puis encore deux colonnes sur la 7ème ça
devient extrêmement tendue et mais si je
fais sa b4 lecavalier bouche et je perds
quatre
donc c'est pas possible donc en jouant
b4 les blancs bloc se plomber 5
il contrôle aussi la casse et cinq au
passage ce qui est pas mal parce qu'on
avait dit lecavalier pouvait envisager
de venir en c5 pour attaquer maintenant
c'est plus possible donc c'est un petit
coup positionnelle
qui contrôle une case de développement
qui bloque le pion adverse et qui donc
permet tours 1 il y a plus b 4 pour les
noirs et donc le cas et c3 n'est pas de
loge abl voilà ils protègent de 4 500
pour être attaqué donc ce petit coup n'a
l'air de rien il est très important pour
faire des manoeuvres ultérieure car ce n
est évidemment pas tout à fait compris
tout ça il va simplifier la position
avec une très très jolies manoeuvres
regarder ça tours 6 voilà bien jouer
tout aussi ce très intéressant vis-à-vis
tout retour ça veut dire quoi
mais les noirs ils envisagent de faire
des échanges ici à la tour ici qui
visent ces deux ce pion peut changer à
tout moment jouant ses cinq donc si
alléchant la tour se trouve sur la
colonne c'est ce qui on va tomber il est
tout seul il faut calculer un petit peu
mais ça on voit bien que c'est très
difficile d'aller défendre ça donc on
voit bien son idée il va jouer ses seins
et en faisant un vis-à-vis tout retour
il va en plus échangé une perte de tous
rangs alors le problème c'est qu'il va
doubler les pions mais on va voir
justement c'est ce qui va se passer
tourbes et un pour les blancs les blogs
c'est de contrer l'idée des noirs en
disant bon mais attention hein si tu
prends site une c5
mais j'ai changé une fois je prends 6 1
et le pion mm sera perdue je vais
prendre de la tour du cavalier sans
doute de la tour pour activer mêlée nord
sud c'est pas grave c'est pas grave
parce que derrière jeu contre attaque
tout est sale à mon activité est
terrible je vais le prendre le pion ces
deux et ça va être très simple regardez
ces 5
alors quand un petit problème puisque sa
force quasiment ici tout de suite les
chances de tourner parce que sinon s'il
ne change pas et aura prison b4 et la
tour ses huit attaques depuis le
cavalier attaque l'option ces deux
annonces et on peut pas permettre ça il
faut d'abord échangé on pas perdre de
temps pour prendre comprend maintenant
on peut jouer tranquillement et là on
fait simplement le meilleur
c'est bien sûr car il prend bessengue on
accepte les changes généralisée des
pions si on avait tenté pions prend ces
scènes ça marche pas tout simplement
parce que les noirs jouent tout reprend
ses cinq bien sûr maintenant que la tour
est tombé 1 c'est pour ça qu'il n'a mis
je peux aller prendre en bessin du
cavalier mais dans ce cas là on sait
d'où tombent aussi un voilà donc c'est
la même
donc en fait il fait après prise y prend
mais celles ci n'ont cédé noir encore
pris l'initiative ici on prenait en d4
et maintenant simplement reprend et
voilà bon en plus et la tour donc
contrôler à taxer deux et on peut pas
vraiment défendre ça et en plus on
regarde et mène alors le fameux pions
leucate et en plus en prise donc les non
et s'ils peuvent choisir lequel pions
ils prennent d'ailleurs en soit ces deux
soit soir quatre bons rails réfléchi car
c'est ni si karine avons réfléchi il
reprend en d4 donc en faisant ça on peut
donc qui protège le cadre donc les noirs
se venger sur ces deux voilà les
échansons fini on a échangé les purs lol
tout petits soucis qu'on pourrait se
dire c'est quand on est petit on doublé
bon c'est vrai et puis un doublé en plus
séparés c'est un léger avantage
effectivement pour les blancs le
problème c'est comment profiter finale
tour cavaliers comme ça bon c'est
difficile de manoeuvrer ici parce que
imaginons que le roi mais 9,7
on peut faire un échec en d6 c'est vrai
quand même si un peu on peut harceler un
peu ce roi mais on peut pas tenir -
cavaliers en d6 une fois que le roi
étant f cède qu'à l'échec en scène le
bouquin les bouges difficile d'aller
chasser ce roi soit il est en 7,7 il
protège bien le 5 est protégé par le par
le par le cahier 17
et puis cette tour peuvent à pouvoir
aussi harcelé peut être un pur le pion
aux quatre avec le câble et le cisq
attaque la tour pour qui pour attaquer
et puis surtout le roi blanc vous allez
voir les blancs font quand même le coup
de l île et 6 ça protège le kart
ça remet le cavalier un petit peu vers
le centre ça empêche live set
bon ça retarde un peu le développement
noir mais simplement ici car scène fait
échec
un nom qui vous empêche 2 et tour ces
deux voilà ils répètent et wissous
laurent blanc l'a du mal maintenant
aller vers le centre comment je protège
ça je peux pas laisser tomber ça parce
que si ça s'attendent donc seulement je
perds en bio en mission mais ça l'est se
plie aux quatre isolé dans ce cas la
position complètement
sera davantage des noirs les chrétiens
de plus mais bon avec un doublé bon ça
c'est le cas même quasi nul est très
difficile de faire quoi que ce soit donc
la seule solution pour les blancs
d'éviter maintenant le perpétuel sont de
nouveau un échec ça se fait de venir en
g3 bon mais ça c'est dangereux c'est
dangereux parce que il peut se passer
les trucs on peut imaginer par exemple
ici on pourrait envisager pourquoi pas
cavaler g5 échec 3 4 est maintenant en
plus oui lecavalier pourrait venir en f4
ou se meut vrais attaquants g2 f2 est
toujours attaquer on pourrait aussi
pourquoi pas envisager cavaliers l'autre
cavaliers qui vient f6 ici et là
attention et prévoir des menaces de
maths parce que regarder ça c'est
contrôlé par le cavalier ça c'est
contrôlé par les cavaliers g5 seimat
quoi on est obligé de donner à une pièce
en quatre voilà donc c'est quand même
tout petit peu embêtant imaginons ici
que les blancs jouent encore g4 ici dans
cette position attaquée le lecavalier
hcl mais on peut jouer g5 qui gagne pas
tout à fait une pièce avance car si j'ai
cinq cas elle les prend et on prend roi
prend duquel il se protège mais celui-là
il est attaqué donc s'il faut se bouger
si on le bouge de mon père le cavaliere
ont là par contre c'est la catastrophe
donc ça marche pas donc la g400 sort
mais en fait dans ce cas les noirs ici
c'est pourrait simplement jouer qu'à
tours prend un f2 tout simplement je
gagnais plus au passage si les blancs
prennent du plomb ici ils ont des pions
complètement complètement jeu on prend
le cavalier en lennon en gros avantage
donc bon donc c'est dangereux d'allonger
trois ris c'est dangereux parce que ça
ça crée une grosse situation de tension
donc vous êtes obligé de revenir un peu
en juin et voilà en répétition de coûts
car scène où la caille king propose nul
et larsen comme ils s'apprêtaient à
refaire échec au rejet de courage de
toucher 2 ça fait ça fait partie nul
voila donc vous voyez que c'est une
nouvelle et c'est pas trop trop gras
parce que l'activité de la tour noire
est forte
le point 4 est encore un peu isolées
même le petit avantage positionner blanc
de les blancs n'ont pas le temps de le
consolider là pour le mettre pour le
mettre en jeu voilà une jolie partie un
petit peu dans le style de la première
avec
je dirais avec comme ça une bascule une
bascule en finale technique et bon
carrière qu'il a essayé une ouverture un
peu un peu atypique de l'espagnol là
avec et detroit avec quatre heures voilà
des petits coups on voit que ça gêne pas
car celle là il n'a pas été gênée à
aucun moment on l'a senti sous pression
il a très très bien joué
simplifier vers la fin voyez partie
tranquille donc je dirai après ses deux
premières parties léger avantage très
léger pour qu'arsène qui a été un peu
plus je dirais un peu plus agressif dans
la première que kara keane dans la
deuxième et quiberon mais qui n'a rien
obtenu
bon évidemment donc pas soit on sait
c'est pour l'instant un match nul
deuxième partie nulle le championnat
continue bien sûr on attend une première
victoire mais c'est à ce niveau là
évidemment c'est pas c'est pas toutes
les parties qu'on peut qu'on peut gagner
voilà donc c'était intéressant et ça va
permettre maintenant de placer le jeu et
de voir sur les parties suivantes
comment les joueurs vont varier mais ce
qu'ils vont forcément varié par rapport
à ce qu'ils ont déjà joué et c'est ça
qui va être intéressant dans un match
c'est ça qui est intéressant dans un
match c'est cette cette stratégie de
variation de d'ouverture pour voir ce
que les joueurs ont préparé
il teste un peu le terrain voir ce que
les joueurs adverses ont ont prévu de
jouer et en fonction de ce qui est de ce
qu'ils voient ce qu'ils observent et
bien ils sortent leurs armes parce que
bien sûr ils ont des armes préparé pour
ce championnat et il ya des parties où
ça va devenir bien sûr extrêmement
tendue voilà donc merci de m'avoir suivi
un pour ce deuxième partie du
championnat du monde 2016 entre carsen
écart et akin à new york donc en 12
parties sur d'agaune al tv donc je vous
donne rendez vous pour la troisième
partie à jour de repos la prochaine le
prochains jours donc c'est dans deux
jours et toujours pareil ça sera donc là
par l'émission sera disponible en
matinée voilà merci d'avoir suivi et à
bientôt sur l'honnêteté
au revoir